et que pascal mousset président génie
paris ile de france je précise que le
groupement national des indépendants est
le premier syndicat hôtels et
restaurants en région parisienne le
deuxième au niveau national également
direct avec mon direct de calvi jean
pierre pinelli vice président du cercle
des grandes maisons corses bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france pour réagir donc
à ces annonces d'edouard philippe pascal
mousset bonne nouvelle donc pour la zone
verte qui va pouvoir ouvrir sans fin on
en parlera évidemment des restrictions
mais a priori sans condition en revanche
la zone orange c'est moins évident
puisqu'il faudrait être doté d'une
terrasse ce soir qu'est ce qui prédomine
chez vous comme état d'esprit que tant
de soulagement la satisfaction parce que
réouvrir pour nous c'est retrouver nos
clients remettent des collaborateurs au
travail
donc ça va dans le bon sens et cette
situation depuis le 15 mars devenait
intenable sur le plan humain économique
et de couper notre métier notre passion
ça devenait compliqué maintenant on est
bien conscient que c'est une demi-mesure
on aurait espéré comme nos collègues de
province passer au vert et ré ouvrir
plus largement
aujourd'hui beaucoup de restaurateurs ne
dispose pas de terrasse et je tiens à
préciser notamment pour la région ile de
france et pour paris que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui les conditions
administratives d'extension de nos
terrasses et donc aucun restaurateurs ne
peut aujourd'hui s'adresser à la mairie
et dire je souhaiterais rajouter des
tables et table à tel endroit et on va d
confiné nos terrasses après un week-end
de trois jours dont un jour férié le
lundi
donc ça va être extrêmement compliqué de
réagir
rapidement pour accueillir nos clients
et élargir le terrain c'est espérer
faire un petit peu l'activité
donc oui demi mesure on va revenir
évidemment sur ces restrictions je me
tourne vers jean pierre pin et les
vice-présidents de faire des grandes
maisons corses
vous êtes soulagés jean pierre pinelli
pour vous la situation est plutôt
favorable encore des zones vertes la
saison et ce qui va les sauver
ça y est ou c'est peut être trop tôt de
gafsa non c'est trop tôt la saison n'est
pas sauvé d'abord je voudrais une
d'avoir une pensée pour ceux qui vont
affronter la maladie et est le co vie
parce que c'est vrai que de l'aspect
sanitaire ne doit pas on doit pas
l'oublier
d'une part deuxièmement satisfaction etc
et que eux justement cette situation
s'améliore et qu'on va déjà pouvoir
emboîté le pas sur le discours
économique et nous sommes satisfaits
parce que ce qui nous importe c'est
évident nous les professionnels c'est
d'abord c'est cette notion descendre km
qui me paraissait un petit peu peut-être
un peu forte du moins car on est c'est
une économie d'amis des mobilités vous
savez aujourd'hui le surtout le tourisme
donc ça nous paraissait même un peu
juste de ne pas pouvoir se dépasser des
100 km alors vous vous êtes plutôt
sauver entend ce parce que les terrasses
ça y est quasiment que ça les hôtels
vont rouvrir vous quelle est votre
situation des propriétaires d'hôtels
également vous allait rouvrir rapidement
les choses vont se passer de quelle
manière très difficile pour nous dans
l'immédiat dans la mesure où non à une
contrainte c'est celle d'orly tang
l'aéroport d'orly n'ouvrira pas y
compris ce 26 juin sauf erreur de ma
part c'était l'une des annonces
effectivement de la journée de la part
des doigts philippins oui mais voilà 26
juin effectivement annonce afp
l'aéroport d'orly qui va donc ouvrir le
26 juin tout à fait donc sur la france
continentale est difficile il n'est pas
difficile de se déplacer on a plusieurs
moyens de locomotion pour nous c'est
essentiellement l'aérien qui dit un
petit peu le devenir la saison donc on
attend avec impatience l'ouverture
d'orly d'une part et d'ensuite vous
savez que nous sommes encore en
discussion sur ce fameux green parce que
le président exécutif a eu cette idée je
ne sais d'où le doubs il l'a prise mais
du moins là évoqué et pour le moment on
n'a pas eu on attendait une réponse du
premier ministre ce soir à ce sujet
qu'elle sait qu'elle est là les
conditions et comment le gouvernement
veut gérer cette ce green basse on
attend on verra dans les jours à venir
du moins le mois de juin malgré
l'autorisation du 2 juin est pour nous
très impacté pascal mousset vous
comprenez justement nos valeurs
effectivement se protéger ce green pass
on veut relancer l'économie bien
évidemment on veut retourner au travail
mais voilà avec beaucoup de sécurité et
des garanties
je pense que ça dépasse le cadre de la
corse la distanciation physique que nous
impose cette maladie est contraire à
l'adn de nos métiers et l'adn de nos
métiers c'est de rapprocher les gens
c'est très la convivialité de rapprocher
les gens plutôt que les éloigner donc
nos entreprises elles resteront
durablement impacté tanka distanciation
physique sera de mise et il ya que les
médecins et les spécialistes qui
pourront nous dispenser de cette de
cette contrainte
donc on est les secteurs du café de
l'hôtel restaurant discothèque tous ces
établissements sont vraiment
économiquement très très fragile
et pendant toute la période des mois qui
vont qui vont arriver malgré l'ouverture
aujourd'hui économiquement on est tous
contraints à travailler à perte pendant
une durée indéterminée et ce caractère
indéterminée et la maîtrise du temps
qu'on n'a pas va précipiter beaucoup
d'entreprises qui n'ont pas de
ressources sur le long terme dans des
difficultés et mélasse dans la
disparition
aujourd'hui notre combat il est de
minimiser l'impact sur les entreprises
en étant accompagné on a quand même un
sujet des loyers que moi je je trouve
important parce qu'aujourd'hui les
dispositions législatives ne permettent
pas de faire plier les bailleurs et les
bailleurs aujourd'hui peuvent très bien
depuis le 15 mars exige l intégralité
des loyers est dire le vide ne nous
concerne pas et du côté des entreprises
que l'on défend les cafés les hôtels
restaurants on a derrière des impacts
sociaux et de l'emploi et nous on
demanderait aux bailleurs et on demande
aux bailleurs et à tous les
propriétaires d'hôtels café-restaurant
de tenir compte de ce phénomène toko ide
et d'adapter pendant deux ou trois
trimestres leur demande de loyer voire
de les annuler sur la période de
fermeture ce qui est une demande
récurrente qu'on a depuis plusieurs mois
et le président macron nous a
accompagnés dans cette demande le 24
avril il a invité les collectivités
locales à annuler les loyers pour les
entreprises de notre secteur d'activité
pardonnez moi mais vous vous dites on va
être condamné à travailler à perte
pendant quelques mois
on va y revenir parce que c'est vrai
qu'on prend beaucoup de temps pour les
réponses sur ces deux mesures quand même
restrictive mais ça veut dire tu auras
des établissements qui vont être tentées
finalement de ne pas rouvrir ça peut ne
pas être si rentable pour eux d'ouvrir
par exemple jean pierre pinelli vous
avez été sur vous de vouloir rouvrir vos
hôtels tout de suite au final on peut se
poser la question et mettre les choses
en balance il est évident que cette
saison on aura pas d'entente habilité
ici des gens ne perd pas d'argent
c'était c'est un exploit on peut pas si
vous voulez après ce choc qui est
inhumain mettre en route nos entreprises
et se dire qu'on va retrouver d'abord
quel fréquentation on va t'on avoir
comme le disait monsieur les mesures
barrières sont est assez contraignante
et en même temps il va y avoir un choc
émotionnel qui va se pour le moment on
est un peu aseptisé par ce choc mais le
évidemment il y aura un choc émotionnel
et psychologique qui va suivre alors 10
portable maximum les mesures de
réflexion un mètre entre chaque table
pascal on sait comment vous voyez les
choses on imagine que c'est beaucoup
plus simple selon les établissements
je tenais pas tous logés à une enseigne
le petit bistrot qui a 25 places
aujourd'hui est en danger si en plus il
a pas de pire à ce je vois pas comment
il peut s'en sortir
les établissements qui ont plus de place
qui disposent de terrasses pourront plus
facilement s'adapter et recevoir et
avoir un petit peu de chiffre d'affaires
pour remettre leurs collaborateurs au
travail
la différence qui nous sépare entre
calvi et paris c'est que calvi attaque
la haute saison et la corse la pac à
tout le littoral attaque la haute saison
donc l'opportunité pour ces
établissements d'avoir un petit petit
d'affaires est plus importante
du fait de l'appétence des français de
ceux qui pourront se déplacer a quand
même profité des vacances sortir de ce
contexte anxiogène qui nous accompagne
depuis le 15 mars
nous à paris on est dans la situation
inverse on attaque la basse saison à
partir de la mi juin les grandes
métropoles se vide notamment paris
cette année 15 millions de touristes
étrangers ne viendront pas les grands
musées sont fermés il y à l'attractivité
de paris s'en trouve fortement diminué
et donc que nous attaquons la basse
saison donc l'opportunité que nos
entreprises et 1 ne serait ce qu'un
équilibre est complètement hors de
propos
aujourd'hui l'essentiel des activités de
restauration et d'hôtellerie vont perdre
de l'argent à paris pendant les trois à
quatre mois qui viennent cette
incontournable il n'y a plus de marché
si vous voulez il ya il n'y a pas de
mende il ya une offre pléthorique donc
on voit pas comment économiquement
équilibrer nos exploitations à parler
une petite structure qui ont très peu de
frais de personnel qui ont très peu de
collaborateurs
quand des petits loyers pourront
peut-être tiré leur épingle du jeu
mais les structures un peu importante on
connaît les loyers parisiens vont se
retrouver très vite en difficulté à
l'automne dernière question jean pierre
pinelli la tentation peut-être pour
certains d'augmenter les prix
cet été justement pour compenser un
petit peu surtout pas vous savez avec la
reprise c'est la reprise dès que les
frontières seront ouvertes ce sera la
reprise des autres pays aussi
puisqu'elle vous le savez ça échappe à
personne ça a impacté la planète et les
autres pays feront aussi des prix et
vous le savez on est difficilement
concurrentiel sur l'offre déjà qui est
qualitative peu partout en europe et
au-delà apprenez le maghreb on va pas te
le manuel et en même temps ces gens-là
rebonds ont eux aussi baissé les prix
donc il est difficile ils n'ont pas les
mêmes codes sociaux et le cob même code
fiscaux c'est pour ça que je vois ce
monsieur sait que le gouvernement et
l'état devront faire des efforts
colossaux pour monétiser pour injecter
des liquidités sans quoi il faudra
recréer le cercle vertueux si vous
voulez delà de la production de la
consommation et de la fiscalité c'est
impératif
on me penche sur grand merci à vous en
tout cas je conclus sur un sondage
plutôt optimiste pour vos 84% des
français se disent prêts tout à fait
prêt retourner dans les bars cafés
restaurants lors de leur réouverture
selon un sondage opinion way en tout cas
bonne chance à vous merci d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france